mais
et
9 hectares de terrain six mille mètres
carrés de bâtiments le domaine de
l'abbaye de pontigny est à vendre
propriétaire du site depuis 2003 la
région ne veut plus un supporter la
charge
une décision difficile à accepter pour
le maire de la commune
c'est le goût de son 250000 euros à
l'année nous on a un projet qui peut
ramener de l'argent qui peut réduire un
peu le trou puis à terme en évolution en
évolution ramener de l'argent ça soit
rentable mais on n'a pas les moyens de
départ ont une petite commune en eau
ça sera le musée est en bas il y aura le
réfectoire et en face ce sera le master
class voilà il y aura plusieurs places
pour recevoir des élèves
l'ambition est de faire vivre le site
d'habiter tous ces bâtiments vides
[Applaudissements]
autour de l'abbaye de l'ordre bientôt
restaurée musée de l'hôtellerie ou
encore des jardins bio pour
l'association ces activités payantes
garantir et à terme l'équilibré
financier au bout de deux ans on était
au top
on n'avait pas eu besoin de la région
pour pour continuer voilà on a porté une
boutique monastique
on a porté de loisirs de la visite de
jardin tout était fait pour pour la
culture et le tourisme
près de quarante mille personnes
visitent chaque année l'abbaye de
pontigny mais l'entrée est gratuite
donc pas de recette déjà on cherche
l'équilibré pour la région et au delà
sont excessives une billetterie payante
c'est aussi l'une des propositions des
amis de pontigny l'association un autre
projet pour le site mais pas les deux
millions de demandes et par la région
ces bénévoles se disent inquiets pour
l'avenir du domaine la plus grande qui
restent nous voulons être vigilant que
cet esprit du lieu ne soit pas perdue à
travers elles et les acquéreurs
potentiels
le risque je crois existe puisque elle
est bien consciente aussi que
l'acquéreur souhaitera peut-être avoir
un retour sur investissement
la région elle se veut rassurante un
cahier des charges strict et précis
devra être respecté nous sommes dans un
site quand même voilà qui a toute une
histoire qui n'est pas bien sûr l'abbaye
de pontigny ça n'est que le domaine de
continuer mais il ya cette proximité il
y à des bâtiments également qu'ils ont
leur histoire et il est important
effectivement que tout cet aspect
patrimonial et culturel soit soit
préservé
les potentiels acquéreurs du domaine de
l'abbaye de pontigny ont jusqu'au 17
octobre pour se déclarer
à ce jour trois candidats auraient
manifesté leur intérêt pour le site
mais la région n'aurait pas encore reçu
aucun projet ni offre concrète